you fool especially if one is
broad-minded about thinking about all
the ways that one can engage in
rent-seeking
one can actually be destructive of value
if you destroy future well-being for our
descendants
it may look productive in the present
but it isn't productive it's actually
destructive so that's a kind of
rent-seeking that we don't even
typically model but we're where were we
headed so oh yes so we live in a game
theoretic landscape that's both good and
bad as you point out competition is a
healthy thing and competition in markets
produces a huge amount of value so I
hear people deriding capitalism and I
always want to make the same point to
them which is you've got two things
glued together and you are challenging
them as a package but there's no reason
they have to be packaged so we would be
foolish to give up markets markets are
amazingly powerful engines of innovation
they are capable of solving problems
that we cannot solve deliberately even
if we want it to so we need markets but
we don't want markets ruling the planet
and deciding that anything that spits
out a profit is therefore good and that
we should be exposed to whatever the
market discovers can be viable so what
we want is ultimately to provide and
provide incentive structures that cause
the market to produce things that are
good for us right in other words if you
tell the market that you want the
solution to some problem the market can
figure out how to solve that problem and
it will do it very well but if you allow
the market to decide what problems to
solve it may end up for example
addicting you to your phone right
addicting to you to your phone in a way
that harms your social relationships
harms your your parenting of your
children harms all kinds of things that
are really important breaks the ability
of your children to have a educational
experience in school we don't want the
market discovering how to disrupt useful
functioning of people
we want the market to stay out of that
stuff and then to provide us benefits
that only it can provide like all of the
mechanisms that now allow us to navigate
seamlessly in places that we've never
been avoiding traffic that we wouldn't
know to worry about right those are huge
benefits and they're capable of taking a
city that is too snarled with traffic
and reducing the degree to which it it
is snarled with traffic so they're very
powerful but we shouldn't we shouldn't
throw the baby out with the bathwater
markets are good allowing markets to
discover any and every mechanism for
exploiting you is not good at all and in
fact it's a large part of why we're in
the predicament that we're in is that we
let the market decide what problems to
solve and then if it solves them and
they're very lucrative there's no way to
say no once so there aren't they detract
of two people I mean that's one of the
reasons why our phone is so addictive is
because it's attractive because you can
get access to information at the drop of
a hat so you just constantly want to
feed that machine you constantly want to
let go what what can I do can i play a
game on it who can I take a picture
myself ooh can I give myself a dog nose
ooh right but imagine I mean it's it's
amazing to me that it's even hard to do
this thought experiment but put yourself
in you know in your own mind 15 years
ago and present yourself the deal that
the phone represents you know hey Joe
all right check this phone out right
this phone is going to allow you to
navigate in a place you've never been
it's going to connect you with all sorts
of people who share your interests
you're gonna be able to say a sentence
that you think is clever and suddenly
hundreds of thousands of people are
gonna be able to react to it I mean all
sorts of marvelous things and then the
point is well here's the downside okay
you're gonna be hooked into mega
corporations that are gonna study your
psychology and they are going to compete
in order to keep you paying attention to
their site and we're going to become so
sophisticated that you're going to lose
control over your own
mind you are going to become addicted to
it in the way that you might become
addicted to nicotine right so that
that's a pretty high cost what's more
you are going to surveil yourself you're
gonna surveil yourself and your only
protection from surveilling yourself are
gonna be end-user license agreements
that you're not going to be legally
sophisticated enough to understand and
so you're gonna be at the mercy of
whoever has access to your phone camera
your metadata your you know all of these
things so the point is if you said this
to you 15 years ago you'd know to be
afraid of it right I probably wouldn't
want to be like yeah I'll put it down if
I don't like it okay well I must tell
you if you told me that I was gonna be
bugging myself with a sophisticated
device like that then I don't know I
can't even I can't even turn it upside
down because there's a camera on both
sides of the dam right right I mean the
cost is really high but we signed up for
it incrementally in a way that never
left the ability to say Brian oh and
what's worse it is now inconceivable if
we discovered that the net cost of such
a device exceeded the value of it by 10
times we still couldn't get rid of them
you can't pull them back you can't
unmake them there's too much benefit to
them though you're you're making it seem
as if it's only a negative but it's not
only a negative it's also answering
every single question you could ever
have about anything technical anything
involving history anything involving
facts and obviously in today's day and
age with hashtag fake news you're gonna
get a lot of facts in there as
well but just to shear access to
information they be able ability to
contact each other instantaneously
there's a lot of pros to a huge number
I'm believing I'm not underrating the
value of I mean just you know you
pointed it to it yourself having even
just Wikipedia in your pocket is like
that's such a fantastic gift to have
that access to information not only on
your home computer but right there in
your pocket that's amazing so I'm not
saying the benefit isn't spectacular and
you know I've signed up for it like
everybody else but the cost is very high
and didn't have to be
in other words if you had set the bounds
in which the market was going to solve
this problem so that you for example
prevented it from breaching our ability
to protect our own privacy you could
have had the benefit of Wikipedia and
instant communication and all of these
things without the huge downside so the
the privacy issue being cookies or
cameras like which which one are you
referring to well first of all I think
the cameras are a bit of a red herring I
don't think anybody at first of all
there's a huge amount of data involved
in video to the extent there's an issue
it would be more about the microphone
mmm and the fact that it can listen into
conversations and basically track who's
thinking what and there's so much power
in that potentially that even even if
it's not being used presently it's only
a matter of time before somebody taps
into that data and starts using it to
shape things they are not entitled to
shape